la politique ce soir sur antenne 2 c'est
bien sûr la suite du débat à l'assemblée
nationale c'est encore l'heure de vérité
à 22h 30 ans marie de virieu invité jean
marie le pen qui répondra aux questions
d' albert du roy d'alain duhamel et de
jean marie colombani
entre autres sujets la stratégie
actuelle du front national qui consiste
à pénétrer tous les secteurs de la
société française notamment l'université
bruno roger-petit et bruno carette ont
enquêté à sciences po ou le représentant
du front national vient de réussir un
bon score aux élections universitaires
toujours là il est arrivé un peu en
retard
il est vrai que régis poitevin de la
croix vaubois n'est pas un habitué des
commémorations du 8 mai 1945
un coup d'oeil à françois mitterrand une
légère moue normal régis poidevin de la
croix vaubois et militants du front
national mitterrand c'est le président
de tous les français où c'est un
président socialiste
c'est un président socialiste depuis
1981 est-ce qu'il est reposé et excusez
moi et c'est aussi le président je crois
beaucoup d'étrangers et ce 8 mai 1990
jacques chirac le gaulliste qui évoque
une extrême droite complice du nazisme
jacques chirac est encore moins en grâce
fait si jacques chirac croit qu'il peut
ramener à lui les électeurs du front
national par ce genre de calme ou et
notamment les jeunes
il se trompe lourdement et ça me fait
vraiment le fait que d'un esprit malade
régis poidevin de la croix vaubois
connaît donc son jean marie le pen sur
le bout des doigts
il faut dire que c'est un élément
brillant car ce jeune militant est aussi
étudiant à sciences po depuis trois ans
il y milite avec ses amis du front des
résultats 7% des voix cette année aux
élections universitaires
après une campagne plutôt chic et pas
très choc c'est peu mais c'est aussi
beaucoup à sciences po où le front
national n'existait pas jusque là
dans cette école d'où sortent de
nombreux cadres supérieurs de
l'administration du privé cette percée
de l'extrême droite est une nouveauté
nouveauté qui illustre parfaitement la
stratégie de pénétration du front
national à l'intérieur du système
universitaire par deux crânes rasés
pas de violence tout se passe entre gens
de bonne compagnie et ça marche
tous les indicateurs nous font devenir
absolument optimiste que ce soit les
contacts avec les jeunes à l'université
et house arrivons à monter de plus en
plus de sections où que ce soit au vu
des sondages où que ce soit au vu des
élections partielles ce qui vous arrive
de doute que jean marie le pen je n'en
ai pas eu l'occasion
les adversaires de jean marie le pen y
sont prévenus à l'université comme
ailleurs peu à peu le cercle des amis du
front national s'agrandit